♪ ♪
>> Sean: AS WE TOLD YOU GOING
TONIGHT'S OPENING MONOLOGUE, NEW
PEW RESEARCH POLL, THIS IS HUGE.
IT COMES TO THIS ALARMING COLD
POLLUTION.
MORE AMERICANS ARE WORRIED ABOUT
FAKE NEWS THEN TERRORISM, THAT'S
HOW MUCH DISTRUST RIGHTLY EXIST.
THE TIMING OF THE BOOK CANNOT BE
ANY MORE PERFECT, IT IS CALLED
"UNFREEDOM OF THE PRESS."
NOW NUMBER 12 WEEKS IN A ROW ON
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" BEST SELLER
LIST, BECAUSE IT IS FULL OF
HISTORY IN SUBSTANCE, THE
TYPICAL MARK LIVE-IN BOOK, THE
HOST OF "LIFE LIBERTY AND LIVE
IN" ON THE FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
AND HE WOULD NEVER ADMIT IT
PUBLICLY, BUT A FRIEND OF MINE.
THERE IS A REASON ALL OF YOUR
BOOKS GO TO NUMBER ONE, BECAUSE
THEY ARE FULL OF SUBSTANCE.
AND I READ IT COVER TO COVER,
AND I READ HER BOOK, I LOOKED AT
THE RESEARCH POLL, AND I LOOK AT
A PRESIDENT THAT HAS TAKEN ON
THIS CORRUPT MEDIA AND TWO PLUS
YEARS OF LYING, CONSPIRACIES,
AND A HOAX, HOW COULD ANYONE
TRUST THEM?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, SEAN, I WILL
TELL YOU WHY I WROTE THE BOOK,
BECAUSE THE MEDIA WILL NOT SELF
POLICE, THERE IS NO
CIRCUMSPECTION, THERE IS NO
RECONSIDERATION.
THERE IS NO SHAME.
AND THERE REALLY NO STANDARDS
LEFT.
SO IT IS UP TO WEEK, THE PEOPLE
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE MEDIA
SINCE THE MEDIA WILL NOT LOOK AT
THEMSELVES.
THAT WAS NOT ALWAYS THE CASE.
I WROTE DOWN A FEW THINGS HERE,
PROBLEMS WITH MOST OF THE MASS
MEDIA TODAY.
NOTICE THAT I DO NOT CALL THEM
THE FREE PRESS, BECAUSE THEY DO
NOT EVEN UNDERSTAND WHAT A FREE
PRESS IS SUPPOSED TO BE OR THE
HISTORY OF THE PRESS, BECAUSE
THEY ARE DESTROYING A FREE
PRESS.
THEY COMMINGLE NEWS AND OPINION,
PSEUDO-EVENTS.
THEY MANUFACTURE EVENTS, WE
SPENT THREE DAYS TALKING ABOUT
THE WORD NASTY.
HOW PREPOSTEROUS.
THEY PUSH PROPAGANDA FOR THE
PROGRESSIVE IDEOLOGY.
AOC IS FAMOUS, NOT BECAUSE SHE
IS SMART OR PROFOUND OR BECAUSE
SHE HAS ACCOMPLISHED ANYTHING,
BUT BECAUSE THEY WANT TO PROMOTE
HER AND HER AGENDA.
SOCIAL ACTIVISM, CLIMATE CHANGE,
IS THERE ANY INDIVIDUAL OF CNN
OR MSNBC IN THE NEWSROOMS WHO DO
NOT PUSH CLIMATE CHANGE?
THERE IS NO DIVERSITY OF
INTELLECTUAL THOUGHT.
NONE.
THEY HAVE A VAN PURSUIT -- FOR
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AGENDA.
AND THEY PROMOTE THAT AGENDA DAY
IN AND DAY OUT, IN FACT, THEY
LEAD IT.
THE REASON WE TALK ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT TODAY IS NOT BECAUSE
A PRESIDENT COMMITTED ANY
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSES, IT IS
BECAUSE THE MEDIA AND THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WANT TO REMOVE
HIM.
THE REASON WE SPENT TWO AND A
HALF YEARS TALKING ABOUT
COLLUSION WITH RUSSIA, A
MANUFACTURED STORY, A
PSEUDO-FAKE EVENT AS THE
PRESIDENT CALLS IT.
NOT BECAUSE THERE WAS ANY
EVIDENCE, BUT BECAUSE THIS IS
WHAT THE MEDIA WAS PUSHING, DAY
IN AND DAY OUT.
THEY ARE NOT DEFENDING THE RIGHT
ON THE FIRST AMENDMENT OF
FREEDOM OF THE PRESS.
WHAT IS THE PURPOSE OF FREEDOM
OF THE PRESS?
WHY IS IT IN THE
FIRST AMENDMENT?
IT IS NOT IN THE FIRST AMENDMENT
BECAUSE OF CNN OR MSNBC, OR THE
CORPORATE OWNERSHIP, OR ANY
SPECIFIC SO-CALLED JOURNALISTS.
IT IS IN THERE FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
WHY DO WE HAVE FREEDOM OF THE
PRESS?
WE HAVE FREEDOM OF THE PRESS TO
EXPAND FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
AMONG THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE POINT OF NEWS AND NEWSROOMS
IS TO GIVE US THE INFORMATION
THROUGH WHICH WE CAN MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT OUR FAMILIES,
OUR LIVES, OUR GOVERNMENT, OUR
COUNTRY SO THAT WE CAN BE
INFORMED PRIOR TO THE BEST PLACE
TO FIND IT RIGHT NOW IS LOCAL TV
NEWS.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO FIND IT IN
THE VAST MAJORITY OF NEWS
OPERATIONS AT THE NATIONAL LEVE
LEVEL.
>> Sean: I DISAGREE, YOU GET
IT RIGHT, RUSH GETS IT RIGHT, I
GET IT RIGHT.
EVERY SINGLE NEWS ROOM IN
AMERICA FELL FOR THE LIES, THE
CONSPIRACIES, AND THE HOAX.
WE HAVE ED HENRY AND
CATHERINE HERRIDGE.
SPEAK UP AT SEAN, NEWSROOMS,
NEWSROOMS, NOT TALK RADIO, NOT
OPINION SHOWS.
AND THEY LOOK DOWN ON ALL OF US.
AND THE FUNNY THING IS, THEY ARE
AS MUCH OPINION AS THE REST OF
US.
AT THE DIFFERENCES WE ARE
TRANSPARENT.
WE TELL PEOPLE WHO WE ARE.
WE DON'T PRETEND TO BE SOMETHING
THAT WE ARE NOT.
THESE PEOPLE WHO ARE REPORTERS
TODAY, NOT ALL OF THEM.
THERE ARE SOME EXCEPTIONS, BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THE GENERAL RULE,
THEY DO NOT UNDERSTAND HISTORY
OF FREEDOM OF THE PRESS.
THEY DO NOT EVEN UNDERSTAND THE
VALUE OF FREEDOM OF THE PRESS.
MOST OF THEM ARE NARCISSISTIC.
MOST OF THEM DRAW ATTENTION TO
THEMSELVES.
WANT TO DRAW ATTENTION TO
I CAN GO DOWN THE LIST.
THAT IS NOT NEWS, THAT IS NOT
SERVING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THAT IS NOT FREEDOM OF THE
PRESS, SO THE POINT THAT I WANT
TO MAKE TO YOU IS THIS, THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
IS THEIR TARGETS RIGHT NOW, BUT
OVERALL IT IS THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
PATRIOT PRESS WAS THAT THEY
WANTED TO FUNDAMENTALLY
TRANSFORM GOVERNMENT.
THE PRESS TODAY WANTS TO
FUNDAMENTALLY PROTECT IT.
THE GUARD OF BIG GOVERNMENT.
AND IF YOU OR SOMEBODY FROM THE
OUTSIDE AND HE WANT TO CHALLENGE
IT, YOU ARE SOMEBODY FROM THE
OUTSIDE AND YOU WANT TO LIMIT
IT, CUT IT, REARRANGE IT, YOU
ARE THE ENEMY OF THE PRESS.
THEY TALK ABOUT THE PRESIDENT
SAYING THAT THEY ARE THE ENEMY
OF THE PEOPLE.
THE PRESS HAS ITS OWN ENEMIES.
TODAY THE PRESS WANTS TO
FUNDAMENTALLY TRANSFORM, NOT
GOVERNMENT, BUT THE AMERICAN
CITIZEN.
BUT THE CIVIL SOCIETY.
THAT IS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE PATRIOT PRESS AND THE PRESS
TODAY.
IT IS A DISASTER.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, GREAT ONE,
"UNFREEDOM OF THE PRESS" FOR
FOUR WEEKS, Amazon.com,
BETWEEN THEM AND